قال مراسل الجزيره في سوريا ان مظاهرات
خرجت بعد صلاه الجمعه في عده مدن وبلدات
شمال غربي البلاد احتفالا بالذكرى الثانيه
عشره لانطلاق الثوره السوريه واضاف
المراسل ان المتظاهرين ردد هتافات تؤكد
استمرار الثوره حتى اسقاط النظام ومحاسبته
والافراج عن جميع المعتقلين وتحقيق كامل
مطالبها كما رفع المتظاهرون شعارات طالبوا
فيها المجتمع الدولي بمحاسبه النظام
السوري وحلفائه على الجرائم المرتكبه بحق
المدنيين طيله سنوات الثوره والضغط على
النظام للافراج عن الاف المعتقلين في
سجونه وكشف مصير الاف المختفي نقصرا
من اعزاز بريف حلب ينضم الينا عمر
الحوراني عمر انت وسط هذه التظاهره
المطالبه كما اسلفنا برحيل النظام
والافراج عن المعتقلين
والكشف عن مصير المفقودين قربنا اكثر من
المشهد لديك
بدايه هي ليست المظاهره الوحيده هناك عدد
كبير من المظاهرات خرجت في ريفي حلب وايضا
في ادلب وريفها وهذه المظاهرات طلبت
باسقاط النظام كما ان هذه المظاهرات ايضا
طالبت بالافراج عن المعتقلين وكما نشاهد
ان هناك حشود كبيره خرجت في هذه المظاهره
في الذكرى الثانيه عشره للثوره السوريه
وحيث رفعوا يعني مطالب طالبت باسقاط
النظام كما انهم ايضا طالبوا بتنفيذ
القرارات الامميه لسيما القرار
22-54 وايضا ياتي تاتي هذه المظاهرات على
وقع الزلزال الذي حدث في السادس من فبراير
شباط الماضي حيث تضررت هذه المناطق بشكل
كبير وراحه ضحيه هذا الزلزال
الالاف كما هجره الالاف وايضا الان هم
بحاجه الى مساعدات وهذه ايضا لم تغب عن
المظاهرات حيث طالبت طالب المتظاهرون هناك
بالاسراع بمساعده هذه المناطق لكي يتغير
بها الحال وهنا نشير الى ان معظم سكان هذه
المناطق هم من النازحين الذين هجروا من
المحافظات السوريه الاخرى وهم يطالبون
بالاسراع في حلو رحيل النظام لكي وتامين
عوده امنه لهم الى مدنهم وبلداتهم في في
المحافظات الاخرى التي هجروا منه والتي
هجره منها النظام ويقول المتظاهرون هنا
انه على المجتمع الدولي الضغط على النظام
وذلك للافراج عن المعتقلين
وافراج
وايضا كشف عن مصير الذين هم مغيبين في
سجون نظام كمال طالبو المجتمع الدولي ايضا
بمحاسبه
النظام ومرتكبين الجرائم بحق الشعب السوري
وهذه المظاهرات مستمره وهناك دعوات
لمظاهرات خلال الايام القادمه وذلك ضمن
هذه الاحتفاليه في الذكرى الثانيه عشره
لهذه الثوره وتستطيع من خلال الكاميرا ان
نشاهد هذه هذه الحشود التي اجتمعت هنا في
مدينه اعزاز كما ان هناك ايضا كما ذكرنا
مظاهرات اخرى في مناطق اخرى تصلنا ايضا
انباء عن خروج نقاط بشكل متزايد في مدن
وبلدات ريف حلب وادلب وذلك في هذه الذكرى
وايضا للتجديد والتاكيد على مطالبهم لا
سيما مطلب اسقاط النظام اليك شكرا لك عمر
حوراني في اعزاز